welcome back to controversy in Premier
League football now where a number of
clubs are reducing the salaries of
non-playing staff but not their big name
stars in wake of the corona virus
pandemic the professional footballers
Association has warned its players to
speak to their union before accepting
wage cuts are they've been criticized by
politicians for living in quotes a moral
vacuum
well the broadcaster and former England
player Gary Lineker joins me now
hi Gary so I mean it's not really a
great look is it when Premiership stars
or maybe a hundred grand a week and not
taking pay cuts when people are being
laid off at football clubs maybe I think
premature on this first performance it's
only in the last couple of days that
clubs have announced their particular
measures they were clubs announcements
of course not players announcement which
is a key difference so let's see what
transpires over the next week or two as
we all know we're kind of following the
curves of Spain and Italy and in those
countries in the last few days we've
seen players and take voluntary cuts at
the likes of Barcelona Juventus through
a couple of weeks ago so I think we're
kind of following in their path in all
sorts of things tonight's pair and hope
and think it's right that footballers
will try and do their bit as we all get
together in these extraordinarily
difficult times yeah I mean I suppose
the point is what the fans will think
many of fans will have lost jobs taken
pay cut certainly employers may be going
bust tough times for the self-employed
and these guys they're seeing sort of
still getting their Millions
well as I say that's that's the case at
present but don't think for one minute
this is not being discussed by players
all around the country they'll be fully
well aware of this they're very young
men teenagers early 20s they need a
little bit of guidance on this PFA from
my experience and don't always get the
best guidance but sir and that remains
to be seen but I think it's very
important that term football does play
its part in this football will suffer
massively of course there's football
without football
means economic disaster for a lot of
clubs obviously the Giants will survive
but it's really worrying for those
further down the leaves but I'm sure the
big stars are the big clubs looking at
this and looking to do the right thing
it's not something that they can just
make a decision overnight they have to
have a degree of togetherness on this
I've got no inside information and if in
a week's time we're still in the same
position then I'll start to doubt it as
well but I honestly think that we will
hear things from players and I expect
probably in the next few days but we'll
wait and see yeah I mean they do have
whatsapp groups they're not training I
get your point they're not training but
they do have whatsapp groups so it could
you know organize something but what
sort of thing what sort of thing could
emerge do you think there could be where
some of the pay goes to lower league
clubs that may be struggling to survive
what what sort of thing could emerge do
you think well I think that's why it's
probably taking a little bit of time I
would imagine they're getting to go the
YouTube people so yeah it's difficult
for them to all have meetings at the
moment obviously you talk about whatsapp
groups etc but from my experience of
football clubs of which I've got a lot
you only have a number of few players
that you actually get on with the rest
of them you don't so it's probably not
that easy also they are looking at
various ways probably of helping whether
it's erm the staff at the club's if the
club are not doing that which has only
just been revealed whether they have
lower league clubs lower league players
where they just take it cutting wages or
whether they take their wages and then
make donations into certain areas there
are all sorts of different possibilities
that that players can do and I hope they
do do and you think what will it be
individual initiatives or do you think
this could be a joint some sort of
Premier League initiative I don't know I
I think it could be one or the other I
think it could just be players on an
individual basis or it could be
togetherness of players at one club and
then another Club will follow suit I
hope I'm right feel is nerve feeling
positive about what they'll do at that
time time will tell but there are all
sorts of avenues own to but
I suppose the problem is that with the
delay or perceived delay the you know
you open up the opportunity for
politician so the chair of the Culture
Media sport committee Julian Knight says
the situation is obscene and he wants a
windfall tax now on Premier League clubs
that refused to cut the salaries of
stars wildcats at cutting salaries of
other staff yeah is that the further the
term voted against them banks paying tax
etc I think and and voted against people
getting benefits there are of
disabilities etc but we know nobody's
making a fair point he's making a fair
point he's guilty not a yes he's jumping
on a bandwagon and everyone wants to
make that boy immediately let's have a
bit of patience a little time and give
the players a chance to respond this
news only broke yesterday or the day
before about Tottenham and one or two of
the other clubs it's very new so the
players would have to kind of deal with
that in a way the clubs are thrown plays
a little bit under a PR bus if you like
it's now up to the players how they
respond let's give them a chance to
respond before it's hugely judgemental
pile on that we always get nowadays and
you know what footballers are always an
easy target obviously but you know what
I hate what about tree but we're the big
businessman where are the CEOs of these
enormous companies what are they doing
at them at the moment nobody's ever
seems to care about them but footballers
who do an unbelievable amount of good in
the community generally that never gets
reported on who do lots of things for
people who are doing lots of things to
raise awareness during this dreadfully
difficult time so let's let's wait and
see and see where they go to criticize
them if they do nothing yeah Daniel but
you're right there are loads of people
earning millions of pounds and you know
in the city and running companies and
people on telly I mean there are people
do that you think more people should be
you know putting their hand in their
pocket right now do you it's it's up to
the individuals concerned I'm just on my
high horse but I've done something I
think it was important it's not like the
right thing to do
what other people do is their business
but I think in these times of huge
pylons and this we're all massively
judgmental particular on social media
before they've actually done anything
wrong no player that I've heard of yet
has come out said oh there's no way I'm
taking a page but there's no way I'm not
donating some of my money none of them
have done that if they did that then
we'll have to talk about it
but at the moment it seems a little bit
premature to me to be hypocritical what
and what review what have you done do
you mind saying what you've done a few
weeks now except you could see this
tsunami coming and I just felt that
taking the full salary maybe not the
right thing to do and then I thought
what do i do do I just not take a salary
and then I thought actually on what I
prefer to do is with that salary the net
salary is is to put it into a cause I
went with the British Red Cross I did I
was thinking of PPE in and and the mask
switches and the an testing which is so
important but you know from the
conversation I've had it's not really a
question of funds and money it's just
logistical issues etc so in the end I
went with the British Red Cross
brilliant at work them before that
they're focusing on those most
vulnerable in society the most
marginalize the over 70s people with you
know difficult social isolated positions
when they're old homeless refugees
people that haven't even got gene haze
women's victims of domestic abuse which
will obviously be brave for presence so
that's my decision what other people do
is is up to them so I donated a couple
of months worth of net salary okay and
just finally and this seems trivial with
everything that you know this programme
has been about for the last few weeks
the football season I mean you know what
happens do Liverpool it's a very
difficult situation isn't it it did so
difficult more and what to do what will
they do and obviously they'll be
legalities involved in decision making
as well the whole thing's so fluid how
long do we go on I think in
ideal world in some way shape or form I
think we'd all like to see the season
finished except for those that don't
like Liverpool properly but but I think
I think the fair thing would be to try
it come up main to finish it
you couldn't of course then go straight
into the next season because they
wouldn't need a pre-season but then
there's pre torna it does it's so
complicated in the bigger picture it's
not the most important thing in the
world as we've discussed earlier a lot
of people's jobs were at stake with you
and not risk the big big stars it's I
wish I had an answer I genuinely alright
well look Gary thanks very much for
joining us